The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I want to
say a little bit about Hexion
to relate to where we are
today and then do biodiesel,
which is a great case.
Obviously if Darren were
making his own decision,
if Darren were the CEO or
Darren owned the company,
then his decision to use
combined heat and power
to generate would reflect
his preferences, whatever
they happen to be.
And if Darren was
consistent over time,
you could predict
Darren's decisions
from his past decisions.
But it's a committee.
And the case doesn't go
into-- in my modification,
the case didn't really go
into who was on that committee
and who the doubters are.
But it's clear he had to
get by a group of people.
And there's no guarantee that a
group of people is consistent.
They had different questions.
You could read into
those questions
different preferences about
downtime, different worries
about bonuses.
You couldn't really tell--
again, you'd have to have a lot
more than the questions they
asked or the objections
they posed to predict
what the decision would be.
It sounds like Darren would
have just run the spreadsheet
and done it.
But others, who knows?
The terms that Cohen,
March, & Olson use,
this is a group with
problematic preferences.
And groups have
There's no reason in
principle why groups are
consistent in making decisions.
You may recall we did
this voting paradox
thing some time ago where if
I have preferences arranged
correctly, I can get any
decision I want by deciding
which pairs you consider first.
So there's no reason that a
group would be consistent.
And in fact, if you think
about just that committee,
you'd like to know
who shows up, you'd
like to know what
arguments are made,
you'd like to know
who's prepared,
you'd like to know what other
items are on the agenda.
If you've been in committees,
you know how this works.
Sometimes somebody
will lose an argument.
And to keep that
person on board,
they get to win the next
one, et cetera, et cetera.
So Cohen, March, and Olsen talk
about problematic preferences
in organized anarchiies
like universities.
The only point I
want to make here
is that if you
think about Hexion,
and you think
about Darren trying
to get this project approved
through some kind of committee,
that story holds--
who shows up, what are
they interested in,
what are their motivations,
how prepared are they, what
other issues are up that day.
You can't assume
consistency, and you may not
be able to predict decisions.
So we're going to
see some of this,
and we're going to see
some other features.
We'll see this, and we'll
also see some other things
in biodiesel which
has to do with a more
complicated and presumably
anarchic organization--
us.
So the story you all know, a
student-led group, simple goal,
you take the used cooking oil
and convert it into diesel fuel
to replace the diesel--
save the reprocessing
cost and use it
in tech shuttles,
other equipment.
Lots of diesel
engines around campus.
I assume you've
all read the case.
There is a short video
that's actually--
if I can get it to work, it's
sort of a nice description
told by the participants.
And I'm going to
refer back to this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Animal, so animal weight.
- The whole biodiesel
from used vegetable oil
is definitely a
good idea because it
reduces waste as well as
creates a useful product.
- Biodiesel MIT, the student-run
organization that's been
working to get a biodiesel
processor installed on campus
is going to take the used
vegetable oil from campus
dining from fryolators and all
that kind of stuff and convert
it into fuel for the
tech shuttles on campus.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: This
was made in 2010, this video.
- So the smell of French
fries [INAUDIBLE]..
- I got involved because
I heard about biodiesel.
I was working in
renewable energy.
- I heard they were looking
for someone to do some testing.
- When I got here as a freshman,
I was really looking for some
sort of energy and [INAUDIBLE]
environmental initiative.
- I joined the group actually
as the website manager.
- They needed me
to find them help.
So, I figured I have the skill
set to help with the project.
- I tried from the
beginning to say
this is not a research problem.
It is an implementation problem.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
- The group had been
told, if you get funding,
it'll be easier.
- The project's going to pay
for itself within a year.
- We also wrote up a proposal
for the mtvU GE Eco-imagination
Challenge.
The charismatic view
from mtvU came in first.
And they had balloons,
they had this giant check.
I had to go take a
math test after that.
The administration
had theoretically
supported the project.
- You can parallel
this as people
in a community
going to government
and saying, we
have the solution.
We just need a place
for it, and maybe
incentives, economic incentive.
- I really didn't
think it would take
that much time because the
group had just won $25,000.
- But we had no experience
with implementation.
We have no experience in policy.
- We still didn't have space.
We still didn't
have a processor.
There wasn't really anything
tangible that people could see.
So we lost a lot of, I guess,
recognition and student
support.
- We had the technical
problem solved,
so we thought everything
else was easy.
This experience
actually taught me
that it's actually
the other way around.
So even if you have
the technology,
if it's not going
to be implemented
by the government or
the administration,
nothing's going to happen.
- So we got to a point at
the very end of the Spring
semester in 2008 where the
administrative organization
that had been helping us
look for space basically
just said our least
expensive may turn out
like $160,000 in renovation.
This is really just infeasible.
We're going to stop
looking for space for you.
And I'm sorry, we can help you.
So we agreed that we
would terminate the group.
- We came to a conclusion after
a lot of struggling, especially
because it seemed at the point
that all the effort was wasted.
- There's actually,
like immediately
calling that, a huge
student uprising of support.
Three or four days
later, we get a call
from the Kennedy [INAUDIBLE].
And practically Facilities
was all like, hey,
we can get back again.
We found you space this time.
This is Biodiesel@MIT's
biodiesel processor.
- Being part of the
group has helped
me realize how important the
politics of it all can be.
- I'm so convinced that the
policy is more important.
- It's just pushed me
to a minor in policy.
- Putting different
groups of people
together always produced
pretty good results.
- There have to
be first members.
- Even if you have
a good idea, it
doesn't really matter
if you have to change
the way people do things.
- But after
Biodiesel@MIT, I know
that people will be able
to do things like this
much more easily.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
The group's website
doesn't seem to have
been touched since last
summer, so I don't know
what its current status is.
But they did manage
to produce fuel.
So I'll just run lightly
through the history
because I want to spend
some time on the discussion.
Did that raise any questions
vis-a-vis the case, by the way?
Is that pretty clear?
The first time we
taught this case,
Sara presented it, so
nice to see her again.
So they talked to
the administration
and they were told, if you
have dollars and space, why,
that's great.
They won this award, they looked
for space from the full of 2007
through the spring of 2008,
they gave up, space was found,
and they installed the process.
So they actually
did produce fuel.
And at least according
to the website,
it's in use, or was in use,
at least as of last summer.
So there it is.
It's a nice project
if you think about it.
From the MIT point of view,
it's got some research.
Somebody had to do
the cost analysis.
They had to get
this stuff tested.
They had to get the system work.
They had to design
the logistics,
a lot of interesting
things, good photos.
It comes out a little
murky you will see,
but it can be made usable.
But it took a long time.
And you got the
frustration in that video.
And I hope you got the
frustration in the case.
A project that seemed like
such a good thing, and the case
goes on, it saves energy, it's
clean burning, it's swell,
it took a long time.
So I want to talk about, and we
will talk at some length about
why that happened because I
think this really is a good
case in terms of what it takes
to make organizations change,
that's what this is
about, and why they don't.
So the conventional
explanation, and you
could see it in Sara's
face was, gee, if only
you'd been a better leader,
if only, if only, if only.
The whole Women in Science
Initiative here a few years ago
really did have a big impact,
really did change things.
How come that worked?
How come that went off
right away and this didn't?
The alternative might be
that there was something
about the organization.
And it wasn't a matter of
better or worse leadership.
It was a matter of
strategy running up
against organizational problems.
So I think there are
more things in the story.
What we got in the case, and
what you get in the video,
is they tried real
hard, they gave up,
and then suddenly
the space was found.
And it's got to be more
complicated than that.
So we think--
I think context is
really important.
So let's walk through
a little bit of this.
So in the video, Sara
talks about "and we
talk to the administration
and the administration
was supportive."
And you hear, that,
you hear people
talk about large organizations
in the singular a lot.
BP does this, Goldman
Sachs does that.
The administration does
one thing and another.
Well, it's not a black box.
It's a set of people.
That's just the top set.
That's the top layer.
And there are rules.
That shows reporting
relationships, who reports up
through the provost, who reports
up through the chancellor, who
reports up through the executive
vice president and treasurer,
a little dotted line
responsibility here
from Israel, a Sloan graduate.
She's a Sloan graduate,
but never mind.
If you look at MIT,
there's a formal hierarchy.
I'll show you some more
organization charts.
People report to
people, particularly
outside the faculty
realm, particularly
in the staff side of the
operation, which is what
they were largely dealing with.
They're specialized
responsibilities.
Different people have different
jobs, different things
they're judged on.
And they're a set of
rules, formal, informal,
but mostly formal
rules and procedures
about how we do things.
You can go on the
MIT website, and you
can get the rules and
regulations of the faculty.
You can get a document called
Policies and Procedures that
lays out a lot.
In various other places,
there are sets of rules
deep into organizations.
I mean, it's a bureaucracy.
That's not-- that's a technical
term, an organization that
has all of those things.
Most large
organizations have to be
bureaucracies to
get things done.
You got to have hierarchies
and reporting responsibilities,
and you've got to
divide responsibility,
and you've got to have some
rules for how we do stuff.
That makes for efficiency.
It doesn't make for change.
There are also a set
of informal rules.
Who votes with whom?
Who talks to whom?
Who supports whom?
What are the
communication channels
in this complicated entity?
So, whenever you think about
changing an organization
or about how an
organization behaves,
you got to think about
it in the plural.
It's a set of people, it's
a set of relationships,
it's a set of rules, a
set of responsibilities.
And here are-- oh, yeah,
let's go to the next one.
So this is a description--
I'm not quite sure
where it's from--
of what Biodiesel@MIT does.
They work with-- they have
to work with Campus Dining,
Facilities, Environmental
Health and Safety,
MBP Bioenergy, I think,
was the reactor supplier,
and the Energy Initiative.
And it's designed to do some
training and to make biodiesel.
That's sort of where
this organization
has to be situated,
has to get space,
has to pass Environmental
Health and Safety because things
can go wrong with the reaction.
And you've got a lot
of material around.
The Energy Initiative,
not so clear.
Health and Safety, yeah.
Campus Dining to get the fuel.
Lots of places.
Who was the most
troublesome from the case?
What parts?
Max.
MAX: --trying to
find them space.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That
was the CRSP, the Committee
for Review of Space Planning.
Anybody else troublesome?
Scott.
SCOTT: Also the
Health and Safety,
it was a lot of
different back and forth.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Health and Safety.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They said something
about the janitorial service.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's
facilities basically, yup.
AUDIENCE: And there
were members that
were in class familiar
with isolating systems.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Let's unpack it a little bit.
Let's see, Facilities and
Environmental Health and Safety
report up through the executive
vice president and treasurer.
We can see them there.
This unpacks the organization
from the website.
There's Facilities, there's the
Environmental Health and Safety
reporting up through
the executive vice
president and treasurer.
What are their day jobs?
What's Environmental Health
and Safety's day job?
What are they mostly
concerned with?
They don't exist to provide
space for student activities.
What do they exist to do?
Jacob.
JACOB: I know they do a
lot of safety training
for people for different labs
and students who are working
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So their job
is to prevent accidents,
and incidents, and hazards.
They do training.
They also work
with people to make
sure they're in compliance
with a variety of regulations
and try to instill
best practices to make
the place safe.
They want to reduce risk.
What about Facilities?
What's its main job?
What's its day job?
Again-- yeah, Columbus.
COLUMBUS: To make sure that
the physical buildings are
operating correctly.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That
the physical plant runs,
that it's clean, that it's
warm when it needs to be warm,
that it's cool when
it needs to be cool,
that the plumbing works, the
electricity works, things
are clean and
landscaped and all that.
They're concerned with
the physical plant,
keeping it going.
OK, CRSP, CRSP is a
more complicated story.
Sorry, that's the acronym.
The space planners are a
more complicated story.
But just to give you a sense,
here's-- what do I have first?
Here's Facilities.
So Facilities-- I don't
have people down there.
But there are people
in all these boxes.
That's what
Facilities looks like,
worrying about the utilities,
worrying about security,
janitorial services,
grounds, making sure
the mail gets delivered,
and a whole lot of overhead.
That's the planning, building
new construction, renovation,
and so forth.
A fairly complicated
organization,
not unusually complicated
for an institution this size,
but fairly complicated.
And lots of people.
And everybody's got a job.
Whoever these folks
are, they worry
about getting the
mail delivered.
And these folks worry about
the grounds and landscaping.
That's their job.
That's how they're evaluated.
And you don't see a provide
lab space for students.
Not their job.
Environmental
Health and Safety--
you have to have
an MIT certificate
to get this org chart, which
I don't quite understand.
But I had to type in a bunch
of credentials twice to get it.
But there's Environmental
Health and Safety.
You got folks worried
about the reactor,
a variety of other
responsibilities,
some technicians out here.
A whole set of people
concerned with minimizing risk.
So these are simple,
focused organizations.
So when Sara talks about "the
administration," we talked
to the administration,
the first question
is, who, who did you talk to?
What was that person's
role in the hierarchy?
What was their responsibility?
What rules were they
operating under?
And how are they judged?
Now, let me come to the
really interesting one.
This is CRSP.
I have to tell you in
nine years as dean,
I never actually knew
who was all on CRSP.
But CRSP was like one of--
I can't remember whether it was
a Carter advisor or a Clinton
advisor who said,
when I die, I want
to come back as the bond
market because everybody's
afraid of the bond market.
Well, I'd like to come back
as CRSP because everybody's
afraid of CRSP.
At MIT, space isn't priced.
Departments, labs,
don't rent space.
Space is allocated.
But space is a status symbol.
If you're running a lab, you
want to have a lot of space
because that means you're
active, you're busy.
I mean, those of us
who work at our desks,
we're out of this game.
But in most of MIT,
space is a status symbol,
and CRSP allocates space.
CRSP is a nice
illustration, its processes,
of the garbage can model.
First, CRSP deals with
proposed solutions.
And this is a characteristic
of lots of entities and lots
of organizations.
How can Congress,
when it decides
to actually do something, get
legislation written in a hurry?
Because somebody's drafted
it, somebody's got the answer.
They're just waiting
for the right question,
just waiting for
the right question.
Some years ago when Rush
was moved from September
to later in the year, that
was a proposal acted on.
There was no problem definition
from which that emerged
as the optimal solution.
This is a very standard mode
of operation of organizations.
There are solutions.
If you want to actually think
about another university
example, many colleges and
universities around the country
have abolished their
Greek systems over time.
Was that the optimal solution
to a carefully defined problem?
No, it was a solution
that people put forward,
a proposal that people put
forward that was evaluated.
So CRSP acts only on
proposed solutions,
only on "I need to do this
with this space because," not--
and you can see why.
You can't sit down--
they process many requests
with great regularity.
Particularly this
renovations subcommittee,
which is what's
at interest here,
meets twice a month,
every other week,
and processes dozens of requests
of various sizes, dozens
of requests.
You can't say, is this
the absolute best way
to meet this need?
It's like, is this OK?
Does this work?
Can we do this?
Fluid participation
was a characteristic
of the garbage can model.
Well, look at all those people.
Does everybody come
to every meeting?
Probably not.
Is everybody thoroughly
prepared on every issue?
Probably not.
Does everybody care
passionately about every issue?
Probably not.
And everybody's got, with
one or two exceptions,
has got a day job,
has got a day job.
So, exactly who's active
in making a decision
is going to vary.
It's going to vary.
So if you want to affect it-- if
you want to affect a decision,
you'd like to make
sure that there's
somebody in the room on your
side when the decision is made.
You don't just-- and this is how
you deal with Congress, right?
You don't just make a
great proposal to Congress.
You go talk to people.
You go talk to people on
the committee, and you say,
here's why this is important.
OK, fluid participation.
Who makes the decision varies.
Problematic preferences.
We know CRSP is not
consistent over time.
We know it from the case.
We know it from life.
The case illustrates it nicely.
Can't find you space, it's going
to cost $160,000, boom, here
it is, we found it.
A miracle.
The other thing,
unclear technology.
By "technology" they mean
the decision-making process.
And if you say to
somebody, well,
how come this
project got approved
and this project didn't,
you will hear the argument
that was made for or against.
That's not necessarily why.
That's the argument that
rationalizes the decision.
In any group like
this, particularly when
the objectives aren't clear--
x wants $20,000 to
renovate the lab.
Is that a good
deal or a bad deal?
Well, it's not like we're
trying to maximize profit here.
We're trying to-- who knows,
MIT has a complicated set
of objectives involving
research and education.
But almost everything
that's proposed
will contribute to
research and education.
So which ones can you fund?
Well, exactly how those
choices get made is obscure.
It has to be obscure.
If you ask the people
to describe it,
it would be obscure.
That's a lot of people
in a room dealing
with a lot of information,
again, not atypical.
So when Daniel says, well
it's politics, well, yeah,
but that doesn't help you
figure out what to do.
It's politics in the sense
that there are people making
a decision for other people.
So in a very broad
sense, I use politics--
at the start of the
semester, it's politics.
It's a collective decision.
But if you wanted
to do a better job,
you would want to do more
than treat the administration
as a black box.
And you would want to do
more than say, well, what
goes on in here is politics.
Yeah, OK, what kind of politics?
Who?
Why?
What interests are
people serving?
So this is the background.
I want to spend some time,
and a good deal of time
if we can, on what happened,
what happened and why?
Why did it take so long?
Was this a bad project?
Is this project
inconsistent with the kinds
of stuff MIT tries to do?
You're shaking your head, David.
Not inconsistent.
Good values.
DAVID: [INAUDIBLE] President
Hockfield at that point of time
had stressed the
MITEI initiative.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
And they have 50 faculty
members, MITEI support.
This I think is
the key question.
How come 50 faculty
members, MITEI support,
consistency with MIT values
didn't move this thing
off the dime for all that time?
Andrew.
ANDREW: Because everybody's
not responsible for actually
making the decisions.
Ultimately they first saw
the [INAUDIBLE] concern.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
ANDREW: It falls to
their responsibility
to change [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So all those supporters
didn't have the
power to move it.
Point.
Sam.
SAM: I think just the biggest
issue is the back end.
What the group
planned to do, it'd
affect so many
different operations.
They would need to get the
Dining Hall on their side,
Facilities to help
them move the grease.
They'd need to get the OK from
Facilities to actually use
the biodiesel in their vehicles.
They need to get the space
from the administration.
So it just encompasses
so many different areas.
And that's like five
or six different
like sub-bureaucracies
you have to deal with.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But you
didn't hear the Dining Hall
objecting.
The main objection--
the main objection
was between Facilities,
and Environmental Health
and Safety, and space.
SAM: Well, they did
have most at stake.
All the Dining had to do
is say, OK, we'll leave
our grease on this back porch.
And Facilities, they
had to be the one
to move it, bring it over
to wherever the space was,
pick up the finished
biodiesel, figure out
how they're actually going
to put it in the shuttle.
I mean, it's the
most work for them.
So that explains why
they were most hesitant.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, explain why,
because this is consistent
with MIT values thing,
and it's a good MIT thing.
And the students
probably would have
volunteered to handle
the legwork of moving it.
I don't think we're
talking that much bulk.
Blending it is going
to be an issue.
But blending is blending.
You could probably
do it simply enough.
But then you notice all of
a sudden [SNAP OF FINGERS]
it happened.
All of a sudden they got the
space, the reactor was bought,
and they were moving forward.
So what you're saying
was Facilities resisted.
Why?
What was it to Facilities--
well, go ahead.
SAM: I mean like in Facilities
[INAUDIBLE] was like changing
people's responsibilities,
which I think people,
like it you've been
a role for a while,
and you're comfortable with
that job, somebody says, oh,
we're going to have to implement
this completely new system ,
we're going to balk.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
So for Facilities they
added to their day job.
Christopher.
CHRISTOPHER: I mean, I think
you have to define support, too.
I think any faculty member
would be willing to say, hey,
that's a great idea.
But is it worth it to
them to actually go
out and do something about it?
Like for Facilities,
to get their support,
it has to be worth their
time and their money.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So there has
to be something in it for them
because they have the ability
to block, don't they?
CHRISTOPHER: Yeah.
Like if there was a Professor
that had a research interest
and vested in
this, then he might
be more willing to try and find
some space or vouch for them
with CRSP or
something like that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well that
actually comes to the next one.
What kind of entity is this?
It wasn't a professor's
lab, was it?
It wasn't a live-in group, it
wasn't an administrative unit,
it wasn't a department.
What kind of creature was it?
You had your hand up, Alexandra.
ALEXANDRA: Oh, I was
going-- can I say something?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, of course.
ALEXANDRA: So-- wait.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Hold that thought.
I'll go with Julian.
I'm sorry.
JULIAN: It's a student
organization, right?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's
a student organization.
But most student
organizations don't
handle potentially
flammable equipment
that could do various
kinds of damage,
don't take up-- don't
need to interact--
it's a student organization,
but it's kind of different.
JULIAN: It is a different
student organization.
So because of that,
you have to take
into account like
practicality, where
are they going to get space?
It's not like they
think they're going
to Walker Memorial and whatnot.
Also, most student
organizations don't actually
have a space of their own.
So it's kind of a zero sum game.
Everyone's fighting
over equal space.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
JULIAN: And not everyone is
moving out of your space.
And, of course, MIT--
it's highly sought over
to have space at MIT.
So, I mean,
realistically they're
not going to be able to move in
until someone else moves out.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Or unless CRSP
decides they're very important
because faculty members expand
their labs all the time.
And space is zero sum.
Logan.
LOGAN: I would say that
a lot of the difficulty
stems from the fact
that it's spanned
across a lot of different
types of organizations.
And there are [INAUDIBLE]
is everyone listed up there,
including some others, like
transportation and stuff
like that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Alexandra, good to go?
OK.
ALEXANDRA: What I
was going to say
is like, the fact
that, as he said,
spans across so many different
departments, as well as
a lot of those
departments, their goal
is not necessarily to
make biodiesel work.
So maybe it works with
MIT's general idea,
but Facilities wants
to maintain buildings.
So add-- the MIT@Biodiesel
group probably
adds to their responsibilities.
And also now the space group
has to talk about this.
And maybe they don't
actually want to spend time
if like no one really cares.
So probably it seems to me what
happened was maybe the student
group wasn't pushing
hard enough for it
or didn't know how you go
about talking to people.
And then they quit,
and then everyone else
was like, oh my
gosh, don't quit!
And then--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But we're going
to come to that
because that's a very
important part of the story.
I don't know who was
first here, Ryan?
We'll get all three of you.
RYAN: I was the last one.
But--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, that's not fair.
Erica.
No, go ahead.
RYAN: Well, I was
just going to say
that I think that part of
the problem was that MIT
and many other places
just made the bureaucracy
too complicated.
Instead of actually
deciding on to do anything,
they usually have a meeting
to decide a committee
to decide something.
So I would say that the
reason it didn't get through
was partially their fault
because they didn't know
who to go to, but it's
also partially the fault
that bureaucracy has evolved
into this monster that's
hard to get through.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well-- but to be fair,
this is not some kind
of terrible thing.
And it's not, compared to other
universities, particularly
bureaucratic.
It's that if you want to run
a place this complicated,
you have to have a hierarchy,
and a division of authority,
and a set of rules.
Everybody's got a
Facilities department.
Everybody's got Environmental
Health and Safety.
Everybody has to have a
process for assigning space.
So those three entities
have to exist in some form.
So I wouldn't say
MIT's an example
of out-of-control bureaucracy.
It seems like that
occasionally when
I try to get something done.
But looked at objectively,
I don't think--
it's really good at doing,
it's not good at changing.
That's the way all these are.
Steven.
STEVEN: Well, the first thing
I was going to comment on
was that when you say that
the faculty support and values
weren't sufficient, it's not
that they weren't sufficient,
it's that it's easy
to gain support
from people and bodies
that don't necessarily
have to make the sacrifices
in order to implement
those types of changes.
So that way with the Facilities
and the Health and Safety
groups, they actually
have to sacrifice
other groups and
other possible issues
in order to take care
of this initiative.
And also the fact about space,
I don't know a lot about CRSP,
but I know with certain
other organizations
when they're assigning
spaces, they'll
do it at a specific
point once every year,
that way they review all
the different allocations
of spacing, whether it be
rooms in the Student Center
or other places on campus
and say, all right,
you can use this
space, or this group
is getting this space now.
So I'm not sure if maybe
CRSP, for instance,
says like at the
beginning of the,
year they can
re-assign different lab
spaces, different locations
for other groups as well.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
they operate more flexibly
than that.
Renovations-- that renovations
committee met every two weeks,
and the body itself met monthly.
So if you're going to
put in a big request,
like we want to
build this building,
it may go through
CRSP, but it ultimately
goes to the president.
But for medium-sized
things, they
get decided on a
pretty regular cycle
because you don't
want to wait a year.
You have a big--
you've got a big
grant, it requires
you to install
some equipment, you
don't want to sit around
and wait for a year
to get the project going.
So it operates pretty regularly.
Erica.
You were probably first, huh?
STEVEN: Yeah.
ERICA: I think there's a
lot of, like, instability,
I guess in the process or
uncertainty because I think
when they first got the
GE Eco-imagination grant,
and they are thinking, oh, it's
going to take $35,000 I think
was the number--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Something like that.
ERICA: --and it ballooned up
to $137,000 and came back down
to like--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Came back down.
Isn't that a miracle?
Yeah.
ERICA: But all the
costs that piled up,
this was not only like,
oh, it's a big cost.
Now it's also an
indication that they
didn't realize how far
things were going to go.
And so when you think, OK,
it's not even what, 35,000,
and they think they
know what we're doing,
and then all these other
things start piling up--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Then
they get overwhelmed.
ERICA: Yeah, overwhelming,
and it's harder
to support when you don't
know what the [INAUDIBLE] is.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's true.
It's hard-- they had
faculty support, which
a number of people
have pointed out,
is really pretty cheap and
fairly useless for many things.
But for this one, where you
had to deal with the staff,
quite useless.
David.
DAVID: I was just
going to say I think
it's important to realize that
the people who are in charge
of these communities are
gatekeepers, not necessarily
stakeholders in the project.
So for them to say
no to something
is to minimize their risk
because if something doesn't
go forward, they're really
not on the line for it
unless there's public attention
drawn to their decision, which
is what happened.
And then they had
a choice to make.
There was we do it and we
deal with the consequences,
or we don't do it and deal
with the consequences,
as opposed to doing
it and possibly
dealing with a fire, or
explosion, or something
expensive down the
line, or not doing it
and then it fizzles out and
dies and no one knows about it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
I want to come back to that.
I just do want to
make the point here
that we've danced around, which
is this group doesn't quite
fit.
You could look at
policies and procedures,
and it talks about
labs, and it talks
about the departments,
and administrative, units
and living groups.
And it even might talk
about student organizations,
but not in a way that deals
with this kind of operation.
This is a production
operation run by students.
You can look through the
rules and the precedents,
and you don't find any of those.
So you're giving the
administrative apparatus
with its rules, and
its hierarchies,
and its defined
responsibilities,
and you're giving it a
new kind of creature.
David.
DAVID: There are lots of
student groups that do have hard
allocated spaces
in [INAUDIBLE]----
there's the [INAUDIBLE] City
team and [INAUDIBLE] team
and stuff like that.
And you do power allocated space
with like dangerous machines
and stuff where there is risk.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Some
of those have been around
for a long time, of course.
This was a new one.
DAVID: So maybe it
took them five years
to get space or 20 years.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I also
think the Environmental Health
and Safety stuff has gotten much
more focused in recent years.
I think we've all gotten
much more risk averse.
If you look at something like--
well, I don't know which shops.
I know the ones that used to be
when I was here as a student,
they'd been around for 50
years when, hey, go ahead
play with a drill press.
Who cares?
So it may just be that
there's more scrutiny.
DAVID: There's some
sort of precedent
that these groups use.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: There is.
There is.
I take your point.
But boy, they acted like this
was neither fish nor fowl.
Charlotte.
CHARLOTTE: I was
going to say, I guess,
I think that that's
the answer right there,
that just in today's
world, things take longer.
I mean, I think it's more
impressive that a student
group was able to successfully
carry out this project,
and get approval, and get
a space within two years.
And then now, six
years later, we're
actually producing the product.
I think that's
really impressive.
And I know that two years
seems like a long time
to a college student,
but in the real world,
wouldn't a project
like this take longer?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
would depend, wouldn't it?
I mean, it went real
fast once it cleared.
So I think part of
what we've been saying,
and a lot of people have said
it, was none of the key players
had a positive incentive to
take this project forward.
It was more work
for Facilities, it
was more risk for Environmental
Health and Safety,
it was space from
other uses for CRSP.
So, Arianna.
ARIANNA: I'm not sure I
entirely agree with that.
I think there is some
kind of incentive
as part of [INAUDIBLE]
the overall organization
if this is accomplished, then it
kind of looks good on everyone.
But because those-- it's a
collective action problem.
If not everyone's
pulling their weight,
and because it's taking
all these different groups
to pull it off, if
someone's lagging,
it's a waste of
everyone else's time.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But
if I'm the Facilities guy,
the fact that MIT gets good
press doesn't affect my job
performance rating,
doesn't affect my day--
how well I do my day job,
which is what I'm judged on.
I'm not judged on
MIT's press, I'm not
judged on MIT's
education, I'm judged on,
does the mail get delivered,
does the landscape look good?
And if I'm Environmental
Health and Safety,
I'm judged on accidents.
Are there risks?
Do we comply?
This is not an
opportunity for me.
This is a challenge for me.
CRSP is more complicated because
of its diverse representation.
But Facilities and
Environmental Health and Safety,
this is not an opportunity,
this is a challenge.
For MIT as a whole,
that's a different game.
ARIANNA: I think there's some
trickle down of smiling faces.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
But the whole point here
is not much, in a large
complicated organization,
not much.
Erica.
ERICA: Well, in this
situation, having
MIT look better as a whole would
just affect the Facilities'
and EH&S's jobs.
So they needed to be required to
implement the [INAUDIBLE] pass
as part of their job.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
could be required to.
And in fact, that's
probably what happened.
But when the process is
coming up through them,
there's nobody requiring them.
Sarah.
SARAH: It raises a question
as to the direction
of the rules in the
hierarchy because it
seems like all of the rules
we've talked about thus far
are about proceeding
up the hierarchy.
But there aren't checks
and rules for going down.
So if you brought something like
this to President Hockfield,
she would have the incentive
to move forward with it
and force those incentives
on the people below her.
But it's not able to move
on the other direction.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's the
nature of organizations, right?
You go back to Hexion,
all these folks concerned
about their bonuses with
there might be an outage,
and it might affect
my bonus, and I
can't go to Hawaii
this year, it may
be a great thing for the CEO.
If you can get it on the CEO--
the CEO might say, oh, come on,
we want to be leaders, we
want to get great press,
and the savings are nice.
So for the organization
as a whole,
if not necessarily for you and
your bonus, we should do this.
But if it doesn't get
on that person's desk,
it doesn't go down
the hierarchy.
It doesn't go down.
Andrew.
ANDREW: I assume
[INAUDIBLE] some points.
Somebody brought up
one of the points
that despite--
because if we talk
a little about the
administrations
and how they interact
with each other.
But I think that we
shouldn't underestimate
the importance of the
individual people who
are in that administration.
Like if it happens to be that
that went to the registrar's
office and one day spoke to
person A about the same issue,
and then the next day
spoke to person B,
and they should
discover results,
simply because they spoke
to the right person.
"Right" might be his position,
it might be his mood that day.
It might be the [INAUDIBLE]
who he conferred me to.
So I think that--
I mean, some of you [INAUDIBLE]
previously that it's not always
the administration, per se.
It's the actual people
inside and not dealing
with a black box.
And then if you make it his
personal goal or something
to make sense--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, the registrar
is a good example because
the registrar's office
is student-facing importantly.
Facilities is sort
of building-facing.
Registrar's office is supposed
to solve problems for students.
So part of it's
temperament and ability.
But if you get somebody
good, that's their job.
It's not the job of the
person in Facilities.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I know there are
[INAUDIBLE] differences.
But you can also argue--
I mean, you got to juxtapose
this against, say, maybe MITx,
that you may not be dealing
with Health and Services
and Facilities,
but you're dealing
with other organizations
and so on and so forth.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That have terms.
AUDIENCE: And that went from
idea to ground in less than two
or three months that we know of.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And it
had support from the top.
And the Energy Initiative
got launched with support
from the top.
Casey.
CASEY: So this biodiesel
effort was a solution.
So maybe part of the
problem was that there
wasn't a saline problem
that needed to be addressed
within the MIT community.
I mean, this group
had an idea of what
it wanted to accomplish.
But maybe just the fact that
the rest of the MIT community
wasn't so concerned about the
fuel usage of transportation
that the key players did
not have this incentive
to address the problem because
there wasn't this push.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So,
why'd it change so radically?
Obina.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to a question.
Instead of an incentive, do you
think there was a disincentive?
Because they're doing
the narrative played out.
Students had a great idea, they
get a lot of press about it,
and then they run up against all
these roadblocks within the MIT
administration.
So it's like, oh,
this school project
was stalled by MIT itself.
Oh, are they doing this?
And so suddenly
you start looking
bad in the eyes of whoever
is reading this bad press.
And so maybe they were
like, OK, maybe the guys
up top intervened, like
who's causing the--
who's stalling?
EHS, get your act together.
And then, I don't
know, it accelerated.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Put yourself
in President Hockfield's
shoes and imagine
you're reading The
Tech on May 13,
and you're reading the story.
And as Sara told it, that we've
been trying all this time,
here's what we're going to
do, and it's gotten killed.
Suddenly you react from
the point of view of MIT.
And you talk to
the folks in CRSP,
and you say, surely
we can do this.
Surely there has
to be a way to do
something that has research,
and education, and student
initiative.
And I gather the numbers are OK.
It becomes an
opportunity, not a threat.
It's a threat to Facilities
because it's more work.
It's a threat to Environmental
Health and Safety
because it's got risks,
no doubt about it, that
Adds to their problems.
It's even a threat
to CRSP because it's
competing for space, which is
really valuable in which people
really want.
And here are these students--
with all due respect, students--
who want to take space from
department heads, and deans,
and people like that.
So in a way, it's a
problem for CRSP as well.
You're not going to control
much that matters to them.
But for MIT as a whole,
it's an opportunity.
It's an opportunity to talk
about student initiative,
and environmental
leadership, and lots
of great and wonderful--
learning by doing, hands on.
It's a great story.
It's not a great
story for Facilities,
or Environmental Health
and Safety, or CRSP.
But it's a great story
for President Hockfield.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know whether she called.
I'd be kind of surprised if
the president or provost hadn't
intervened on the
basis of that article
because CRSP turned on a dime.
The case makes it clear.
They turned on a
dime from very risk--
and the environmental
risks went down,
and the space was available,
and the remodeling was cheaper--
all of a sudden,
all of a sudden.
Somebody from the
top did something.
What might they have done?
I would say when Sara first
presented this experience
to this class two years ago, she
said if we just tried harder,
if we just kept after
Facilities, if we just kept
after the environmental people
and talked to folks on CRSP,
was at the right play?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think they
should have realized
if it was in the committee,
identify who they actually
had to talk to because I think
their biggest mistake was
that they found their values--
they thought their
values should be
consistent with the
committee's values.
And it's almost incorrect
to say that it's
consistent with MIT's
values because what we just
pointed out is that the
undergrad-- that the student
body's values are very different
to the administration's values.
Like Facilities might
have their own objectives,
Environmental Health and
Planning might their own.
So in order for them to
have been more effective,
I might have made
sense if they knew
they weren't dealing with
a student representative
or anyone in there who
shared the values of being
environmentally friendly
with the-- and perhaps
that they should have
stressed on other points,
or had someone else [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
hadn't thought about this,
but the question
comes up on CRSP,
there isn't anybody
there, as you
look at them, who has a
primary role in education.
Claude does research.
But either-- this is
the current makeup.
So I'm not sure
who was there then.
Phil Curry was a former dean,
so you would talk to Phil.
Rafael, faculty member,
you'd talk to him.
Grimson, faculty member.
Everybody else-- well,
Claude is a faculty member,
but he has research
responsibilities.
These are the three people
on that committee who have
very broad responsibilities.
Everybody else is Department
of Facilities, Department
of Facilities, Finance,
Project Management, Planning
and Design.
In this case, you have
to take it up the line.
Charlotte.
CHARLOTTE: Well, it also
seems that maybe they
could have tried taking it
to the students initially,
like if they'd gotten--
because it seems
like what happened
in the end was that because
the student body cared so much,
other people took notice.
So maybe they should have
gone about getting a petition
or having some sort of student
body support from that end,
which isn't going offline.
I say that's going--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Right.
That's starting a
social movement,
so to speak, getting strong
and noisy student support.
Yeah, that's another
way because, again,
the top administration
will be sensitive to that,
will be sensitive to that.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I feel like if they
had gotten more support of what
this would solve, if they get
support of maybe the transport
section, I'm pretty
sure even though--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Transport guys,
it's actually a bit
of a threat to them,
too, because the
machinery runs fine,
and we're going to
change the fuel,
and you're telling me
it'll still run fine,
it'll be environmentally
friendly.
But from the point of
view of cutting the grass
and running the shuttles,
there's no upside,
there's only a downside.
From the point of view
of running the shuttles
and cutting the grass, yeah,
it'll be good, we'll feel good,
but I'm not judged
by my emissions.
I'm judged by do the
shuttles run on time.
So I'd worry about that.
AUDIENCE: Besides that,
look at maybe Dining.
If Dining sees this
as an opportunity
to be able to dispose
of that oil in a--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: --safer
or cheaper way.
And even though
there's no one here
who ensures that as a ten
student group get some space,
there should be a
community that can
support Dining if
Dining presents
that as a need for them.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So they solve
a problem for Dining of getting
rid of all this used cooking
oil, and you want
to stress that.
And you'd want to get--
you'd want to get
student activism
of one kind or another.
It sounds like this was a small
group that worked very hard
and burned out.
And that's not the way to do it.
Erica.
ERICA: Also I think if--
I'm not sure how they
pitched it, I guess,
because obviously, there's the
whole environmental "do good"
side.
But if you wanted to get the
support of certain groups
on campus, like department
Facilities or EHS,
you'd probably have
to change what's--
prioritize what's important to
them to make them want to join.
So we keep on
saying how much work
they have to also put into it.
But if you found
something, I guess,
another way to say, like, well,
yes, you're putting more work,
but you see this aspect that's
not only the do good side,
I guess.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I think
facilities would be hard.
I don't know how you make
this a winner for Facilities.
Marie, you're with us, right?
Any thoughts on how they could
have been more effective?
MARIE: I mean, the
main thing that I
can give you is the
thing with Charlotte
is if they had gotten the
students involved earlier--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Broadly involved.
MARIE: Broadly involved
across campus, maybe--
I mean, instead of having
faculty support where they
didn't really specify
who the faculty were
and only faculty in small cases,
if they had gotten a broader
support system that could
really pushed it further out
it would have been helpful.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
might have been interesting
just in terms of
faculty support,
could you get
somebody, for instance,
to put a petition
in a faculty meeting
that the MIT faculty
endorsed blah, blah, blah, as
opposed to we talked to a
bunch of guys and they like it?
MARIE: [INAUDIBLE] just
pretty broad and you have--
yeah, I guess the course that it
covers in chemical engineering,
and they have the core six
that was doing the website
and spanning a lot
of different majors,
and they could have
gotten faculty support
in many different categories.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And even a Sloan
MBA running the
spreadsheet, huh,
to do the cost effectiveness.
Max.
MAX: I think one of the big
problems with this project
is that--
that probably led to
a lot of hesitancy
with CRSP was just putting
that much trust in students
to deliver this product that
MIT relies on or will hopefully
rely on.
And, I mean, student
support, I think,
may have had some factor.
But I think students
are pretty fickle.
And there's a big risk that
if interest in this project
dies out in the future,
how can we keep it going?
What's the contingency
plan for supplying
the biodiesel, which maybe--
I didn't read the formal--
I don't think there
was the formal report
for the proposal--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: We
didn't include it, yeah.
MAX: --but if that had in it
more of a contingency plan
to show that this
is sustainable,
it's not just going to rely
completely student support.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: If you
go to the website-- again,
I assume it's still going.
But if you go to
the website, it's
clear that all
the excitement was
getting it out-- first
of all, doing the study,
getting approval, getting
it up and running, getting
the reactor actually to work,
getting the fuel tested,
dealing with a whole bunch
of logistical issues,
and then it's a factory.
And then it's not so much--
then it's not so interesting.
Sam.
SAM: Like I think the size
getting student support,
the other just really key
thing to getting anything done
is that when you're
dealing with a bureaucracy,
you always need to work--
you always want to work down the
chain of command instead of up.
If from the beginning
they had gone
to the provost,
or the chancellor,
or even like President
Hockfield said, look,
we have this really
cool project.
It saves you money.
But more than that,
it's a great--
it fits with MIT's
mission statement,
it's students taking initiative,
it's hands-on learning.
And then you can get
some of them to--
like a high level
person of influence
to support it from the
beginning, then you kind of--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Boom.
Then it happens.
Then it happens in weeks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
was pretty much was
going to say what Sam said.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
you can just point to him.
AUDIENCE: Would it be entirely
unreasonable to go and knock
on President Hockfield's door?
Like her house is right here.
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, you have
to have some sense of just
how insanely busy her life is.
And the answer is no.
And she's also-- one
of her first quotes
on taking office was "I
don't like surprises."
So no, you want to
work through her office
to get on her calendar.
But that would not
be unreasonable.
You could take a shot at it.
She probably would
push you away.
I'm just thinking
about operating style.
She'd push you down.
But she wouldn't push
you down to Facilities.
She'd push you maybe
to the chancellor,
or maybe to the
dean of engineering,
or somebody rather
than Facilities.
So it'd be worth a shot.
I don't think you'd get
in to see her right away.
But I think you could get
higher up in the organization.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think playing
off the other department
to try and get off that set
train, getting Dining to make
that call could be useful.
But playing the devil's
advocate, what would have
happened if they just did it
and then asked for a grant?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They couldn't.
They had to have
a place to do it.
AUDIENCE: Say if one of the
faculty that was supporting
them would let them do
a shoestring version,
and so they could go to
Facilities with a couple
cans of biodiesel and say,
try this out for a week.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
they're not going to--
if you've got a faculty
member to give up
lab space, which around here
is not one of the easy things
to do--
and plus they didn't have--
I'm just trying
to think through.
I hadn't thought
about this approach.
They had enough money to buy
a reactor, a commercial piece
of equipment.
So they couldn't start
small and scale up
because you couldn't
do it twice.
So you had to be all in.
So you needed a reasonable
amount of space.
And I think finding
a faculty member
to do that-- if they'd done
it, that'd be a way forward.
AUDIENCE: Obviously an approach
I would have shoehorned it
into a UROP.
And then that would
give me money and space.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: UROP is
not going to give you space.
UROP is not going to-- space is
the killer here because space,
it's free, and it's
a status symbol.
So there are no worse fights at
any university than over space.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Ultimately,
it's the faculty member's lab
space, ultimately.
Yeah, let me go back
there, then here,
and then I'm going to move on.
AUDIENCE: And just
one of the thing
I think maybe they
should have done,
and I doubt they did this,
actually look at this.
I mean, I doubt that they
actually sat down and realized
that this is mostly
this department,
and this department, and
those people who know that.
So maybe I think
they're the kind of--
talk to someone, and then
that person from someone else.
I think it was kind of like
learning by doing things.
And I think if they
had some their homework
and sold the structure,
maybe they would have
known to do this versus stupid.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to say going
through the top-down method,
one of the things they learned
later on was that MIT does not
react well to bad publicity.
So working with the
mtvU initiative,
they were the ones
that gave them
the initial grant saying, hey,
we're going to work with them.
They gave us this initial grant.
They want to come
back a year from now
to see what we've
done with that money,
and they want to do a
special piece on MIT,
it would just hit MIT right
away and be like, all right,
now we have to do this.
Otherwise, we're going to
look like complete jerks
for not letting our
students follow through
with their initiative.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And you have
to make sure that somebody
who cares about MIT's image,
and who isn't just rewarded for
delivering the mail on time,
making sure the trees are
trimmed, is aware of this.
So let me move on.
I think we've hit
almost all the points.
Oh, that was supposed
to come on in pieces.
So much for custom animation,
but we can do this.
You really have to
understand the organization.
I mean, every
organization that's
larger than 10 or
15 people ends up
having reporting
responsibilities, a division
of labor, different people
rewarded for different things,
some sort of procedures.
And that makes change hard.
That's not a bad thing.
It's good at getting stuff done.
It's not good at changing.
So, how do you get change done?
Well, there is a tendency
to mimic good organizations.
MIT occasionally
resists this tendency.
There was a story of a
fundraising organizer years ago
that said to a president,
to be nameless, well,
we haven't done
this quite before,
but here's how Harvard,
Yale, and Princeton do it.
And the response was, we're MIT.
What do we care?
Well, I mean, raising money
is raising money it turns out.
And there is a good
thing to imitate.
The other thing we
saw here is whatever
the goals of the
organization are that we all
have tattooed on our foreheads,
people have their own goals.
So in no organization
do you really get,
I live to serve
MIT's grand goals,
or I live to make
money for BP or Apple.
I've got my-- in a lot of cases,
I have my professional norms
and values.
I've got my own career concerns.
And this is particularly tricky
when the organization's goals
are fuzzy, and universities'
goals are fuzzy.
I think-- one can
debate this, but I
think this kind of
issue of goal conflict
is most serious for
the organization
in middle management.
If you're at the bottom
of the organization,
you're delivering mail,
and you get rewarded for
delivering mail well, bingo.
But if you're up the
notch a little bit,
you have budget authority,
you have the ability
to direct others, and you're
concerned about your own career
and about promotion.
And every organization
wrestles with this.
You want to stand
out to be promoted.
But, of course, you
have to be cooperative
for the organization.
That's a standard tension.
Lots of good ideas,
but limited resources.
Pats on the back are cheap.
This is exactly what
happened to these folks.
They trotted around
this idea of biodiesel.
And everybody said,
that's a great idea.
And they were clearly
energized by that.
But that's free, as a
number of you pointed out.
That's free.
That's great.
Division of labor,
it leads to silos.
I mentioned some weeks
ago that when I came back
from Washington, young
and bright-eyed in 1991,
I pushed for Green Lights at
MIT, which Green Lights was
then a new EPA program
that organizations
would pledge to use
efficient lighting when
it made economic sense.
And so I said, why
don't we do that?
It's good press, and
it'll lead to MIT
as an institution to look
at its lighting decisions.
The place is full of
incandescent bulbs.
We can save money.
It'll be great.
And I got pushed
appropriately to Facilities.
And the then crusty
old head of Facilities
said to me, let me
explain it to you.
The light bulbs come
out of my budget,
the electricity doesn't.
OK.
So the notion that I should
put in more expensive bulbs
to save somebody
else's electricity
doesn't work because my
budget's not going to go up,
and I've still got to
replace the light bulbs.
Well, I quit.
I mean, there are only so
many battles you can fight.
And I didn't see
a way around that
without changing MIT'S
budgeting procedures, which
wasn't going to happen.
I think that basically there
was an instruction down
to be more efficient.
We don't put a lot of
incandescent bulbs in anymore.
But around 1991, this
was somewhat radical
that we ought to be moving
to compact fluorescents
and so forth.
But that's a silo.
That's a silo.
The guy at Facilities
had his incentives,
and he had his instructions,
and he was doing his job.
His job was minimize how much
you spend to provide light.
That's the job.
It wasn't minimize
the lifecycle cost
because he didn't
pay for electricity.
Would it have been better if
he'd paid for electricity?
Maybe.
Hard to do, hard to do.
He wasn't graded on it.
The system wasn't in place.
There were formal rules,
divided responsibility,
and he was managing his silo.
So I mentioned the
next one, that space is
unpriced but a status symbol.
There are no more brutal
fights than over something
that's free that
you really want.
Let me just say that.
So when students say,
oh, we'd like some space,
too, this is like going between
the trenches in World War
I. It's not a place you really
find yourself comfortable,
unless you have allies.
And finally, why would
Facilities care about you
folks, with all due respect?
Making you happy
is not their job.
They report to various other
people in the administration.
They do not report to you.
They do not report to department
heads really or to deans.
They report to Facilities up
through the executive vice
president.
So you've got no influence.
So, how does change ever happen?
We did get biodiesel.
And I will say the Energy
minor that a lot of you
were engaged in is
an example of that.
It's the first
interschool minor.
This took several
years of work to get it
through various organizations
because it wasn't an animal
for which MIT had rules.
The notion that--
departments offer minors.
There might even
be a school minor.
But the Energy minor has pieces
from engineering, and science,
and Sloan, and in principle
the other schools as well.
There was no governance
structure for that.
It all made sense.
Everybody approved it.
Everybody's, oh, a great
idea, a great idea.
I just want to make sure
we maintain quality control
and have the usual governance.
Wait a minute, how are we going
to do that without a department
being in charge?
How are we going to do that?
Well, it happened.
A number of faculty
members cared.
The top administration cared.
The problem was solved.
But it was another one of
those things that didn't quite
fit the existing categories.
It wasn't a department,
it wasn't a live-in group,
it wasn't an
administrative unit.
It was a different
kind of thing.
It got solved, a lot of work.
So let me walk
briefly, given time
through the optional
readings, which have
interesting examples of change.
And let me just say a little
bit about each of them.
They're not tough reading, but--
one of them is.
Sharma has an interesting
study of oil and gas firms.
And the question is, what
determines whether or not
they go beyond the
requirements of regulation
in doing environmental
protection?
Because a lot of them do.
Interesting study.
When does it happen?
Well, again, there's a
lot of statistical work.
But I'll just go down the
more likely to go beyond.
First of all, companies,
there's a lot of questionnaires
about attitudes and so forth.
If you view environmental
protection as something
that the company is
about, well, that's
not a Friedman view,
that's a Handy view.
If you have a broad view of what
business is for, you can say,
and one of the
things we try to be
is responsible
environmental citizens.
Milton Friedman would
say, we obey the law.
Handy might say, well,
we go beyond the law
where it makes sense, if you
view environmental protection
as part of the
identity, if you view
the environment
as an opportunity,
an opportunity for
leadership, rather
than a threat to profits.
BP went to Beyond
Petroleum, you may recall.
It viewed the
opportunity as it--
the environment as an
opportunity for leadership.
Now, did it do much
besides advertise?
No.
But it advertised like a demon.
And it viewed environmental
protection as an opportunity.
Again, these firms that view
that environmental protection
as an opportunity to demonstrate
that they're a leader
to make points go beyond.
OK, but this is a
positioning issue,
just like positioning biodiesel
is an opportunity for MIT,
not a threat to
Facilities, gets it done.
So if you view the
environment as an opportunity,
you're going to do it.
Also if you've got
money, that doesn't hurt.
Another-- this is
actually very surprising.
It's a study of
14 pulp and paper
mills in various countries.
And they have different
regulatory systems--
New Zealand,
Australia, Canada, US.
But it turns out the differences
in environmental regulation
don't do much to explain
differences in performance,
which they can measure.
They can measure emissions
per ton or per whatever.
That doesn't do it.
Most did more than was required.
And their conclusion that they
draw, being profitable helps.
Being profitable a few years
before the sample was taken
helps, if environmental
management style was affected
by was the firm profitable.
But they all pointed
to community pressure.
They all pointed to
community pressure.
If you're in a community
that is organized
and vocal on the subject of
environmental protection--
the plant manager lives there.
This comes to the
issue of, would it
have mattered if you'd
been able to organize
100 students to march on the
president's office in favor
of biodiesel?
Well, yes.
They don't have
any voting power.
They're not in any of
those organization charts.
Would it have mattered?
Yes.
It'd be a globe story,
among other things.
That would turn it.
So it was striking-- again,
this is interview work.
It's striking how
often these folks
pointed to community
pressure, sometimes
their customers, but
often their communities,
as to how they decided to
approach the environment.
And this is just--
this they could do by
talking to the managers.
Were they just barely complying
with the law, were they
committed to complying, were
they trying to be strategic
about it, or did
they really believe
in protecting the environment?
And these are
emissions measures.
This is biological
oxygen demand.
This is total suspended solids.
And I forget what this is.
But you see that, depending on
the company's strategy, which
is influenced by the community,
by how much slack they have,
their profitability, you
get better performance
per, well, kilograms per day.
But I think it's per
unit of output, I hope.
Andrew, you had a comment.
ANDREW: However, given
the community, though,
this community
pressure, this means
to indirectly affect the
person who makes the decision?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Sure.
ANDREW: What I'm trying
to say that if it
could be bribing him, it
could be threatening him,
it could be--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No,
they didn't describe it--
they didn't describe
it like that.
Take a look at the piece.
It was social pressure.
It was when you go
to the club, people
say, the river's pretty
smelly today, George.
Can't you guys do better?
When you go to
the grocery store,
people walk around like this.
It's that-- that
kind of pressure
is what they pointed
to, not bribing.
That's not going to work.
ANDREW: Because only--
ultimately though,
should your goal be that I
should influence the community,
or should my goal be I need to
influence that person somehow?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Sure.
The goal should be I need to
influence that person somehow.
But if you can organize
social pressure,
if you can run
editorials in the paper,
you can do all kinds of things.
This one is interesting.
Let me just do it quickly so
I get you out of here on time.
This guy looks at--
first of all, universities
didn't do recycling
until the late '80s.
This person looks at what
kind of recycling programs
a bunch of universities and
colleges around the Great Lakes
established between
the late '80s and '95.
A lot of them went in.
They went in in two forms.
And this is social pressure.
This is a social movement.
We should all be recycling.
Isn't this great?
And universities and colleges
complied in two ways.
Status creation was you
name a recycling director,
you create a new position, you
give it budget, and you say,
you're in charge of recycling.
And the other way is you say
to those folks in Facilities
who we've been bad mouthing
for an hour and a half,
and you say, oh, by the way
you're also doing recycling.
Now, you would expect having
a person actually in charge
of recycling with that
responsibility evaluated
that way would be
more effective.
It doesn't measure it.
What's interesting is he looked
at a whole bunch of variables
that determined, did they adopt
a status creation approach,
did they adopt a role
accretion approach?
Large selective institutions--
selective institutions tend
to have more active
students like you--
and the presence of the Student
Environmental Action Coalition
were all positively associated
with this role accretion.
The small public
schools that seem
to be influenced by
their peers were more
likely to do role accretion.
If you had a chapter of this
Student Environmental Action
Coalition, you were
less likely to do
role accretion, very
significant impact, very
significant impact.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did it say in the
paper for the status creation
if they often got
someone from the outside
to come and take the position,
or if they promoted someone
from within their own ranks?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They actually did.
They actually did say.
And it tended to be
a recent graduate who
had been active in this
area, just the sort of person
you would expect, right?
And let me just
for fun, if you're
looking for something
interesting to do, first look
up SIAC on Wikipedia and
read what it says about it,
and then go to the
group's own website
and read among the most amazing
histories I've ever read.
It's when they say 1996
was a bad year for us,
we lost all of our
funding and staff.
It's a really,
really interesting--
but on Wikipedia, they
have 70 college chapters
and are very active.
This you can read on your own.
It's a summary of some of
the stuff we've talked about.
I'll see you Wednesday
for the quiz.
The quiz will be lovely.
It's closed book.
It does not require computation.
It does, I'm afraid,
require some thinking.
It does not require
a lot of writing.
So please, we all hate the
strategy of, if I put enough
down, I'll get a good grade.
Don't do that, please.
Thank you.